en shanghai una prueba de kobe positiva
es un boleto para ingresar a un centro
de aislamiento como este durante 17 días
james watt que ha estado confinada en
este dormitorio gigante aquí está mi
cuarto en mi cama la cama de mi vecino
condiciones difíciles que resultan
dañinas
y línea las luces del edificio
permanecen encendidas 24 horas al día
esto afecta a la cordura de todos han
pasado 17 días desde que vi la oscuridad
es
no hay duchas y para asearse sólo hay un
lavabo sencillo
le pones agua luego mojas una toalla y
te frotas la piel con ella en teoría
para salir son necesarias dos pruebas
negativas pero aquí los pacientes
esperan mucho más sin explicación es
absurdo y por eso la gente está molesta
por las condiciones no hay transparencia
en las listas de espera de aquí para
salir 24 horas después de nuestra
entrevista jane finalmente pudo salir
pero otros siguen esperando el
confinamiento los ha llevado al límite
esta mujer agotada tras un aislamiento
de varios días se quiebra combinados en
el centro o en sus casas la salud mental
de 26 millones de personas se deteriora
las líneas de ayuda establecidas a
menudo están saturadas esta psicóloga
francesa en shanghai ve cómo aumenta la
ansiedad entre sus pacientes mismo y una
genia jimmy hay estrés y agotamiento y
no hay visibilidad fue una semana que se
convirtió en dos para algunas personas
llevan tres o cuatro semanas de
confinamiento en casa y una vez más sin
poder salir esta incertidumbre es
realmente dolorosa y prematuro esta ola
de kobe 19 en shanghai es la más grande
en china desde el comienzo de la planta
xi jinping dijo que el país no puede
relajar sus medidas sanitarias por lo
que el final del confinamiento todavía
está lejos